I'm amazed that at a five o'clock slot
that we have such a nice crowd now today
so we'll try to make this lively I make
enter a little early perhaps if the
we'll get some of your questions going
on so a couple things get out that I
hope to get out of the presentation
today first have a little fun but the
three things that at the end of the day
I hope that you pick up pick up from
this presentation is a little
understanding of where things are from
an IOT and big data perspective how you
can apply current technologies that are
available to really do some good and
hopefully you get some ideas from that
and we'll look at a few new ideas as we
look forward into the future of
technologies you might be able to
leverage when you apply IOT and big data
to different business challenges
consumer challenges or mission
challenges I'm just a quick correction I
am the vice president CTO the data
center group with Intel I used to work
with Intel and our mcafee and Lockheed a
while back all right so first look at
the foundation Internet of Things and
big data is really easy because someone
from marketing put the single graph
together and made it look really easy we
have 50 billion or more things in the
world and it's growing depending on
who's funding to study we have an
amazing amount of things being generated
from a storage perspective I don't know
if anybody notice a little factoid this
week toshiba published a new CMOS camera
that does 20 meg high definition so you
figure next year sometime will quadruple
the ability to take pictures and save so
i think that numbers going to go up
really quick multiply those together so
we have the things we have the data and
suddenly we're going to create value
from everyone isn't this really easy
well of course it was that easy we
wouldn't have conferences like this so
with all that data that's out there this
chart on the right and I'm not sure the
exact person who put this together but
it is an amazing eye chart six months
ago this was half the size of the number
of different big data or IOT companies
that were emerging out there in the
market
when you see a hyper growth like this of
the number of startups and companies
investing in the area you know
something's happening that they think
there's some great potential out there
and the great potential that's out there
is what you're seeing the lower left
hand cart is the potential of the market
itself I don't actually think the market
itself is driving it from a pure dollar
perspective but today it's one of the
growing markets out there that's almost
creating a new renaissance in the IT and
technology area that's relevant to folks
we have today so from an Intel
perspective hopefully everybody here has
heard of Intel before or a fairly
good-sized company from Silicon Valley
been around for a while hopefully every
time someone turns on their computer
some you're a cute little thing ding
ding and you see Intel Inside we and
others have been working in the Internet
of Things for a long time here in the DC
area you have the intelligence community
the military community they've been
using fancy sensors for years and trying
to collect that information and derive
some intelligence so they could get
their mission done better but we've been
pulling in new or various Internet of
Things items for years it's just
recently relatively speaking the
technology has hit an inflection point
that is starting to be relevant to
business consumers and more relevant for
government in the services that they
provide from an Intel perspective the
verticals we're focused on our areas in
manufacturing industrial energy sector
the transportation sector retail smart
home building and that includes health
healthcare and that would be my use case
study that I'll show you today what's
interesting is when you have all this
data unless it's relevant contextually
relevant to the person who's consuming
it it doesn't have any value from a
technology perspective we don't sell a
lot of Internet of Things parts or Big
Data technologies where silicon company
but what we do try to do is create an
entire ecosystem of technologies and
reference designs that enables the
larger industry to create solutions so
besides the instrumentation of
everything you see in the left hand side
we are putting a tremendous amount of
R&D dollars across that foundation of
servers storage networking device new
technologies in a complete area and then
try and proliferate we've had some big
investments in cloudera which we things
a leader in the Hadoop space to make it
just easier Hadoop is great technology
forward-leaning companies have been
using it for a number of years but it's
still not as easy to use as it could be
and then enable an investing companies
that give you the tools to make it easy
or easier I don't think we'll ever be
truly easy but easier to do something
valuable with that data that you now
collected so you can get those
applications mostly mobile applications
and the hands of people don't do
something exciting with it so there is a
fair amount of technology already you
saw that there's hundreds of little
companies already in large companies
already working in IOT and big data how
might you apply it we announced it's
just about two weeks ago I don't know if
anybody else has anybody seen any of
this information about our work we're
doing with IOT wearables and Parkinson's
I think it's pretty cool did someone say
yes cool our marketing department hit
two people in the room they do a really
great job in fact a lot of the material
I have today is in just Kurt's material
this is material that I pulled from
different teams from across Intel so I
really didn't know a lot of details
about Parkinson's disease I know Michael
J Fox had a whole foundation associated
with this but I thought it was pretty
interesting when I started reading about
it 100 over age 60 has Parkinson's
disease and which is a brain disorder
about 60,000 new folks are having this
disease each year currently there is no
actual quantifiable test that says you
have the disease which is kind of tricky
about this isn't just a us thing this is
a global thing so it's 1 million in the
u.s. 5 million in the world three out of
five Americans will suffer from a
nervous system disease such as
Parkinson's or Alzheimer's as we go
forward in the future
and it's actually caused by the death of
dopamine cells and these cells are
already lost by the time the motor
symptoms appear so once you know you
have it it's you've had it for quite a
while right so you're starting to see
the symptoms so he was dr. James
Parkinson about 200 years ago started
coming up with a subjective diagnostic
diagnosis and if everybody in this room
knows there's qualitative and
quantitative ways of doing things
subjectively which is a really nice way
of saying I'm going to make an educated
guess that I think you have a challenge
or a disease is probably not the way you
want to approach something long term so
what could we do the harness the power
big data let's look at wearables maybe
throw a cloud platform is because nobody
really does anything got to have a cloud
in there somewhere right analytics
program and then how might we be able to
help well first how do we put some
devices to measure symptoms normally
what happens a patient will go to the
doctors and they'll you know they pull
out the charts maybe they haven't a nice
mobile device and they pull out all the
information but there's just collecting
it right and then they don't see them
for six months or three months how about
we give them some weight on measurable
wearable devices that is passive it's
really easy for them they can measure
tremors they might have sleep patterns
their gate which is their movements that
they have through there they're walking
in movements of their arms their balance
those wearable devices create about a
gigabyte of data per patient per day so
you start doing your math and there's a
million people time is a gigabyte a day
if you deployed this widespread wow
that's a lot of data coming in right sit
on Hadoop and then we're going to do
some analytics for some insight so quick
picture of some of the wearable sensors
on the smartphone application that it
runs on now what we're doing is the
fidelity of the measurements that are be
collected are much much better and it's
easy if they have if you have to do
something special every day I don't
think we were going to do it but you
just make it easy what happened
people use it all right there's actually
a picture of the brain here I'm gonna
get back to that the brain here in a
second let's think about the future when
I see something like this I do work in
the data center group and I have the
opportunity to work across a wide range
technologies big data analytics
infrastructure software defined
networking cloud computing if you're
going to take technology in this
particular use case example and we get
wearable technologies out there on the
edge if their Intel we secure them and
bring them back into the big data
repositories if it's it's somebody
else's wearables we have secure gateways
where you can aggregate that data and
look at different architectures and
bring all that data back as well but you
start to have some challenges one is
speed to get information to the
researchers in the timely way and one is
dealing with scale and the different
types of workloads so we're going to
look into the future a little bit first
I think about speed anybody actually
pick up their phone or go to a website
and sit there and say wow it took me 20
seconds to get here so I'm just going to
wait of course not if you click in your
smartphone it doesn't respond really
quick you're like what's wrong with this
one right well Hadoop is a fantastic
foundation and is maturing very quickly
a complementary technology we're seeing
right now some commercial some open
source commercial companies like ASAP
electr hana platform or spark in my
picture here is actually doing all your
big data work in memory that takes a
different architectural approach
different programming approaches but the
speed it isn't just like a little bit
faster we're talking like 100x faster so
if you're asking a question and you want
to give feedback to your stakeholder to
your consumer the difference between one
the two second response time in 12 day
response time its massive difference so
something to think about as you're going
forward in the future Hadoop is awesome
technologies but i think the in-memory
as it gets more mainstream will
complement that and over time you'll see
the two of them
converge together another area where I
think we're taking cloud computing to
the next level is if you're going to
deal with this amount of scale there's
not enough humans on the planet to
manually manage everything automation
through software-defined infrastructure
and having a good experience for the end
user will become more and more important
and this isn't the classic cloud
computing of hey I'm just spending up
some virtual machines that's great we
did that 10 years ago we're talking of
orchestrating everything you're doing
adding a machine language to learn what
the systems are the applications that
are running Polian Schlemmer tree or the
data of your clouds and then looking at
things like software-defined networks
network function virtualization
software-defined storage software to
find security so that you can manage
things at scale one of the other things
I think will be a big difference and
they're kind of going to go back to the
brain in one second most people when
they think cloud computing think general
compute if I need something I just spin
up more stuff I work for Intel it's not
a bad thing spin up more stuff that's a
good thing but the reality is these are
all different types of workloads a big
data architecture based on Hadoop is a
lot different architecture than you have
then general computing and
high-performance computing you know
there's like a top 500 in the world of
the fastest computers in the world and
they're usually lake in places like
Lawrence Livermore or the CERN
supercomputer center and they're doing
this really wild crazy stuff and you
know the elastic question in the you
know three weeks later to get an answer
well one of the projects in Europe is
their mapping and human brain if you
think about like the Parkinson's
information you pulled together that may
be more than a big data architecture
could do I may take some of the results
of that and put it into a
high-performance computing environment
and instead of waiting three weeks get
it back in three minutes or three
seconds and get a result back that and
then can apply to help someone and that
goes also now with very unique
technologies things like I don't know
how technical will get but FPGAs where
you can actually take
those technologies and combine them with
general purpose computing like xeon and
do very unique things very very fast and
then there's of course custom solutions
so when we think big data think beyond
just your traditional big data where
people start thinking of I have the
Internet of Things very unique things
coming out even Intel we came out with
us new fashion watch I guess more people
want to wear it if your watch or your
wearables look cool or something you can
buy it at Barneys or something your big
data which is you know your dupe and
your analytics but think a little
broader of these different architectural
capabilities that are out there so I
think it'll end up making an impact with
the consumer or the state quarter that
you have at a higher impact than you
could in any other way now if you want
to have some fun use some imagination we
actually have a complete developer
program actually gained picked up to
these kits for my kids you know a long
time ago that you have a rector sets and
Legos this stuff is just wickedly cool
they have university programs they have
hackathons now to make it so that
anybody with some imagination can start
making an Internet of Things and then
hosted in the cloud we have you know big
data environments as well as software
development kits that are pretty easy to
use I think it will improve their ease
of use over time so you start building
some very creative things the
Parkinson's example health care and i
think is a great opportunity that's out
there but i think we have just just hit
the tip of the iceberg in unleashing
people's imagination especially kids
love working with kids they're more
imagination than all the adults around
here right maybe how to make money on it
but they definitely have the imagination
up but i have to finish with security
don't forget cyber security when you are
thinking about Big Data and IOT the last
speaker did talk about there are
regulations they have to follow
absolutely unfortunately all good things
sometimes are used for nefarious things
or evil think end-to-end full lifecycle
software and system engineering
techniques so when you build something
someone doesn't take advantage of it for
the wrong thing
you do have to remember whatever you're
building your collecting all this data
the confidentiality of that data the
integrity someone starts changing you
know I can go through a list of bad
scenarios which I prefer not to but I
think if someone changed the data on a
healthcare diagnosis and actually on
purpose gave the wrong diagnosis that
would be terrible right side that
integrity is very important availability
want that impact privacy and other
regulations I did leave a URL here I
don't know if just three weeks ago I'm
not picking on any one company but at
black hats a cyber security conference
that's out west every summer if it's new
someone tries to break into it so about
three weeks ago I actually own one of
the little nest devices which are really
cool technology it must be cool when
Google will pay billions for your
company right it's not based on Intel
chips but it was actually they showed
how compromised it so you know you think
what's the big deal if somebody
compromises your system in your house
that does your temperatures and things
of that way because you have it all set
up so that when you leave it's cool when
you're there it's hotter you know they
think of this as a smart meter actually
one of my kids pointed out well dad if
someone hacked in that they know when I
was when you're at the house when I'm
not at the house and that's when a
burglar could break in I'm like well
it's pretty good think thank you for a
nine-year-old right so Internet of
Things awesome technologies but don't
forget the security even though we can
do great things with it that's it thank
you very much for showing up